[Musique]
il est 21h passé hier soir
dans certains quartiers de paris des
terrasses sont toujours largement rempli
à rennes plusieurs centaines de fêtards
se sont rassemblées après 21h sur linde
sur l'une des principales places de la
ville oui en fait palette il ya
notamment été allumés et du mobilier
urbain a été incendiée regardez c'est
une liberté conditionnelle ce
déconfinement c'est une liberté
conditionnelle sinon on va retourner
on va retourner dans le mur à l'été ou à
l'automne le couvre-feu il est passé
mais c'est important pour toi 9 heures
non là on va rentrer dans un appart on
va aller avec des gens on sera 30 40 on
va continuer jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
des gens aiment rester race bien entendu
mais personne ne veut quand on leur
ferme c'est pas l'objectif dans
l'objectif c'est n'y arrive et on va y
arriver
donc ça suppose comme toujours il
discipline collective
le premier ministre lui même a essayé et
ça donne ça ce qui est factieux c'est
ceux qui fomentent un des troupes contre
l'ordre public est précisément celui qui
a eu des montes liste à la définition du
larousse et dupond moretti
le garde des sceaux a dit hier même
qu'il était dangereux pour la démocratie
d'opposer la police à la justice
toute la classe politique à part à part
ceux qui soutiennent la violence comme
jean luc mélenchon et qui soutiennent
ceux qui agressent les policiers étaient
là mais aujourd'hui les mots ne
suffisent plus on a vu un peu le la
démarche de communication ridicule du
ministre le fait qu'il n'ait pu rester
que 40 secondes dans cette manifestation
traduit bien la défiance et l'état de
colère des forces de l'ordre et les gars
du groupe est resté quarante secondes il
a dû être exfiltré très rapidement parce
que on voit bien qu'il n'était pas à
l'aise les stars de cette manif les
voilà eric zemmour philippe de villiers
gens mais si y'a équipe de rêve se moque
jean michel aphatie sur twitter
n'empêche que cette photo une école près
de 10
aïe aîe ont été applaudis par les forces
de la beaucoup de 2,2 des policiers ont
le sentiment de travailler pour rien et
il n'y a rien de plus terrible que de
travailler pour rien il y avait eu ce
gros câlin qui a buzzé si on les rase
sur les réseaux filmé par boris
karlamoff entre eric zemmour et jean
lassalle député élu au diable les gestes
barrière qui me choque moi si vous
voulez c'est la chanson qui a été choisi
pour l'euro notamment la chanson douce
ou femme pourquoi elle vous fait parce
que youssoupha et quelqu'un qui dansait
dans ses chansons dans les champs
extrêmement virulent qu'il a des paroles
virulentes en bas lorsqu'ils appellent
par exemple lorsqu'il appelle à des
menaces de mort contre eric zemmour
[Musique]
lorsqu'il dit par exemple la france est
un pays d' escroc lorsqu'il chante danse
et chanson la france un pays d' escroc
ils ont volé nos oeuvres d'art ils les
ont mis dans leur expo lorsqu'il dit par
exemple dans ce rêve on m'a seulement
donné que foot en club cette chienne de
marine le pen
ça vous choque pas ça ben moi ça me
choque qu'on choisisse quelqu'un comme
ça si vous voulez pour représenter la
france
on sait qu'il ya deux candidats on a
perdu on sait en revanche que si on
agresse nos forces
oui nos sensibilités qui peuvent être
différentes
nos origines régionales départementales
et bien on peut gagner moi je suis
convaincu oeuvre bluffante de l'artiste
français jr son modèle cette fois la
dame de fer là toi et fais avec ses
enfants oui c'est un énorme gouffre
regarder sous la tour eiffel place du
trocadéro illusion d'optique frappante
il faut le dire c'est un projet qu'il
avait tenu secret il a été dévoilé hier
on a jusqu'au 19 juin pour en profiter